ومن الواضح أنها تجربة بالنسبة لي
جديد لكنني جاهز لدي
الكثير من الرغبة
في نهاية كرة القدم المدينة متساوية فيها
لدي كل جانب
رفيق وصديق داخل
الملابس التي ستجعل الأمر أسهل بالنسبة لي
قوة القوة
وسرعان ما تعتاد على بلدي الجديد
رفيق
وأكرر مرة أخرى أنا متحمس جدًا
سعيد جدا مع الكثير من الرغبة في البدء
هذه المغامرة الجديدة تريد الذهاب إليها
القطار تلبية بلدي
الزملاء لتكون قادرة على الاتصال بهم
معهم
ثم تدريب اللعب
ويبدأ صحيح أن كل شيء لا يتوقف
لنا ولكن أنا مستعد على المستوى
الرياضة ومستوى الأسرة يذهب أيضا
لتكون تجربة جميلة
نحن في مدينة مذهلة و
دعونا نستمتع بذلك أيضا
نحن هادئون وسعداء
لا أعرف ما إذا كنا سنواجه بعضنا البعض من أجل
سيكون الأمر رائعًا إذا لم يتحقق
القائد في جانب واحد سيكون لطيفًا
العودة إلى برشلونة نأمل مع الناس
ذلك عندما يكون ذلك ممكنًا ومن ناحية أخرى
من النادر جدًا ألا أعود إلى الخارج
المنزل مع قميص آخر ولكن هذا جيد
إنها كرة القدم ويمكن أن تحدث وسنرى
هكذا كما قلت للتو
لقد عرفت أشخاصًا ودودين داخل
الحجرات المغلقة
واحد ينظر إلى النموذج الذي يشبه
قلت قبل أن يتحمس ويعيش ما لديه
فرصة جيدة جدًا للحصول على
الهدف الذي يريده المرء أعتقد ذلك
كل من الأب وأنا
كنا نبحث عن نفس الأهداف من قبل
أن تكون منفصلًا ونأمل أن تتناسب معًا
دعونا نكون أقوى ويمكننا ذلك
يمكننا الحصول عليه بوضوح واحد من
كانت الأسباب أيضًا غرفة خلع الملابس
ney بالنسبة لي ماريا يبدو أنني أعرفه
بصرف النظر عن لقاء كل غرفة خلع الملابس و
من أي وقت مضى الاتصال أو
كذلك
فعل الكثير لاختيار هذا المكان
[موسيقى]
بوغوتا